[Music]
[Applause]
uh let me uh let me play Jim Harbaugh's
response for what happened on Saturday
in the tunnel with Michigan Michigan
State
an apology will not get the job done in
this instance
there should be serious consequences uh
for the the many individuals that are
culpable and on behalf of the 2022
Michigan football team our players our
coaches our staff our University
this has been a very traumatic
experience
he uh said that there's an ongoing
police investigation with more on that
let me bring in Kyle Austin he covers
Michigan State uh basketball and
football for M live and he was there in
the tunnel and witnessed what happened
between Michigan and Michigan State Kyle
thanks for joining us how can you uh
update us on but where we are right now
uh you know where we are right now is
really
um it still seems like kind of an
evolving situation you know more video
is kind of trickled out over the last
couple days that showed a lot of
different things going on and a lot of
different players so so Michigan State
as of right now is suspended for those
players indefinitely
um and uh we're waiting on a police
investigation too I mean by University
of Michigan police uh that's ongoing and
they'll be deciding if there's any
charges but um you know certainly don't
think we we've seen and heard all there
is to hear about this what did you see
so I was about halfway up the tunnel um
in a little room off to the side where
we do interviews and
um I'm watching Michigan State players
come up uh pretty unevently for a few
minutes and then all of a sudden it's
kind of a big mob of players uh heading
my way and it's clear there's something
in the middle but there's about 10 or 15
Michigan State players there that are
all shoving you know a couple kicking a
couple throwing some punches and then uh
Michigan player finally kind of sports
out of there and gets off to the side to
safety so you know the whole thing lasts
for probably about 30 seconds but a lot
of Michigan State players kind of
getting up on one Michigan anything lead
up to this other than a lopsided win by
Michigan and the Rivalry between these
two pretty much just those two things
probably a rivalry that I think has
gotten a lot more heated and a lot more
toxic in the last four or five years and
um you know this is this is situation is
totally on the Michigan State players
but the Michigan tunnel situation is
kind of a cauldron for this type of
thing it's a narrow tunnel it's a long
tunnel both teams have to go up it and
you know they were in close proximity
um and they're doing a very heated time
and it was just kind of a perfect storm
for this to happen I think here's the
Michigan State head coach Mel Tucker
Michigan State football is about
integrity
discipline uh selfishness
toughness and accountability the
incidence involved a involving a small
group of our players do not represent
our culture
I think Jim Harbaugh said he had not
heard from Mill Tucker that there was no
apology to him do you have anything on
that Kyle uh as of yesterday when Mel
Tucker spoke he he confirmed he had not
called Jim Harbaugh he didn't apologize
publicly he said he's sorry but as far
as directly to Jim Harbaugh as far as
I'm aware that's not happening and
police charges what do you think the
possibility is that they're filed and
that you could actually go through with
something like this an assault I I think
there's a pretty decent chance if you
look closely at the video and one of the
instances you've got a player swinging a
helmet
um so um not a lawyer but my
understanding is you're talking about
adding a weapon now um to the to the
situation which I think increases the
likelihood and you know look this didn't
happen on the field you know this was
off the field in a separate area so I
think the idea that this is players in a
game kind of goes out the window once
the the game's over and you're off the
field I think they're treated like
anybody else
yeah I just wonder what was said again
it's one thing you might be drawn back
and forth but there had to be it felt
like some trigger words there and then
all of a sudden not that that you know
means you can go attack somebody but no
do we know the one thing that's missing
from here is what precipitated it I
didn't see what started this I haven't
seen any video that showed what started
it I agree it was probably some words
and that doesn't justify what Michigan
State players did but we still don't
really have a clear picture of what
really kind of set this thing off Kyle
thanks for joining us and uh good luck
covering this all right thanks Dan
that's Kyle Austin he covers Michigan
State football and basketball for M live